the international monetary fund
time to rethink global financial policy
in the interview the imf's managing
director christine lagarde
by all means the old german chancellor
is also the new german chancellor angela
merkel you've not always been on the
same page economic policy wise so as the
head of the imf is it a good thing that
she was reelected or not
well first of all i don't think that
she's an old chancellor i think she's a
very
bright energetic and vibrant uh
chancellor and i'm very pleased that she
was uh
she was
re-elected um it's great to have a woman
actually at the help
now this is probably politically
incorrect but i
i think that she brings a lot uh to the
uh
to the economic stability of the region
and we have you're right we have not
always been in
in agreement about economic uh policies
well and and you are asking for example
for a fiscal union down the road for
europe that's something that seems
absolutely impossible with merkel at the
moment so there must be some
apprehension on your part right
well it depends how long the road is
because just as you know a
year ago advocating banking union
sounded a bit like heresy
the situation has changed and there is
clearly
a desire to move towards union and to
implement towards you to implement
banking union with the
appropriate steps with the appropriate
asset balance sheet review with the
stress testing with the common backstop
and with all the
equipment of a proper banking union i
think in the same vein there has been a
lot more
fiscal integration decided amongst the
european partners in the eurozone and
whether it's the six-pack or the
two-pack directives that both bring more
discipline
more attention to
many economic parameters of each and
every member
that that has that is taking them
towards more fiscal union and as you
said
down the road so you think they're going
to come around it might it might very
well take place and we hope that that is
the case because it would significantly
complement and improve
a monetary
zone that is becoming also
a banking union and clearly down the
road being a fiscal union would help
tremendously so basically what you're
saying you think the germans are going
to come around
you know in europe as as the founders of
europe have observed things happen
through crisis
the crisis that the euro area went
through has been transformational
there has been a renewed determination
to
form that eurozone around the currency
around banking union around better
integration of the fiscal policies i'm
sure that the road ahead is going to
continue to have bumps and hiccups and
difficulties
but there will be
a continued journey towards more
integration
now
um of course an important part of the
german policy was austerity
they've been known to be the champions
of that uh when it comes down to
european economic policy there seems to
have been a shift there with the imf
saying that now we have to focus more on
growth and less on austerity even a year
ago there was sort of an acknowledgement
that there was an error in the system in
calculating how austerity really works
in an economy
are you the symbol of this change at the
imf
first of all i would observe that
austerity in new language in german
means discipline doesn't it
we've always advocated discipline
when the objectives are said they have
to be
respected
what we're also saying is that growth
and
fiscal policies
that results in consolidation
are not mutually exclusive and what
we're saying is that it is the pace of
fiscal consolidation
and the type of measures that are used
to consolidate fiscally that need to be
tailored in order to privilege growth
so this is not an acknowledgment that
the imf got it wrong sometimes with the
austerity issue before that
we're never saying that we are always
right who is ever always right
what we are known for is for
acknowledging when we make mistakes
and uh
like in greece for example i will tell
you where we we very uh publicly
acknowledged that we had underestimated
certain factors and that's on the fiscal
multiplier effect of combined
fiscal consolidation around
the euro area and where you know we had
underestimated the fiscal multiplier but
we also said that
even when with the revised fiscal
multiplier we would have designed uh the
program under which greece has reformed
its economy uh in the same fashion why
why why because of political pressure
look at the numbers
it's it's very clear that that a lot had
to be done in terms of
of uh upfront fiscal consolidation uh
for a country that was under huge
financial pressure uh from from the
markets uh it required
very significant structural reforms
and and this is a process through which
the country has gone with huge
sacrifices but we're hopefully they're
turning the corner that it's a country
that is now in very small yet in in in
in surplus at the moment
90 of all the loans of the imf in the
past business year went to europe do you
feel comfortable uh well neglecting the
rest of the world so much in comparison
to europe if i may put it that way do
you know that the largest number of
programs are actually not in europe not
in the eurozone but in africa
so
it's not a question of feeling bad or
feeling guilty we have to help and we
have to serve the membership wherever
there is a need
and
that's what we've been doing after the
second world war in europe
that's what we've been doing in central
and eastern europe after
the iron curtain came down we've been
helping latin america when it needed it
we've been helping asia when it needed
it
it's it's our mission to help countries
that are in in difficulties
wherever they are and
whatever they are but i'm sure i mean 90
is something you say okay this is a
one-time thing and we really have to
change that or am i wrong
it may well be that you know a few years
down the road uh in in a couple of
decades we have to focus all our
energies and resources on a particular
region of the world
uh that that's
you know the nature of our mission but
you do understand there are a lot of
voices from uh countries where they have
developing economies who say that's just
unfair we're not being treated the same
way as europe do you have do you
understand that position
they don't need the support at the
moment but what the entire world is
is stability
if you have a big chunk of the global
economy that is in this array and that
is not being supported and that where
stability is not restored it's hardship
for everybody well egypt for example
would be an example uh
in spite of the political difficulties
obviously that's a country that would be
in dire need of help and and the imf
so far
has not given any loans where were we
there
you know what is
absolutely needed uh for a partnership
with the imf to work is
large political support
and
very strong dedication of the team to
actually enforce the discipline
and make the reforms that are needed to
restore the situation to restore
stability and to create jobs for the
people
as soon as that is there
we are ready to jump we've worked a lot
with the egyptian people over the last
few months and we will continue to do so
believe me
talking about jumping let's go to this
side of the atlantic we as we record
this interview we do have a government
shutdown here in the united states would
you say that's more on the side of
necessary
or more on the side of foolish
i think it's it's bad news
and if it wasn't bad enough the
discussions
currently about the debt ceiling are are
even worse and could have very very
damaging effect uh not only on the u.s
economy but on the global economy
so we are very concerned about about the
uh that potential risk i have
huge trust that this will not happen why
do you have that trust
with the political consolation because i
think it's western churchill who said
that uh at the end of the day the united
states find the right solution after
having used all the other ones and i
very strongly
urge that that happens again
does this situation in the u.s change
your outlook for the world economies
as i said we are very much hoping that
this potential major risk be avoided
and that already changes enough wisdom
around to actually perceive the nature
of this this tremendous risk so we are
not changing our outlook but we're also
looking at the spillover effects that
such
that such as serious damage would have
around the world because there are
economies around the united states that
would that would be hit and the
financial markets could be very very
severely disrupted
because your outlook is quite positive
actually right
it's more it's more complicated than
that it's
there are some good news because the
advanced economies seem to have turned
the corners
but the emerging market economies have
slowed down a bit
so it's it's it's mixed
but if you combine it all
to have advanced economies that are
representing such a large part of the
economy growing finally and to have a
bit of a slowdown of the emerging market
probably means a major transition what i
call the great transition underway at
the moment
so uh
no risk of another meltdown as we had in
2008 has enough been done do you see any
signs well i hope we can avoid that and
i hope that certainly the the the u.s
authorities and the policymakers will be
very attentive to avoid that you know
it's it's it's
stabilizing
that great transition is taking place
and
the economies are as interconnected as
ever so for a very very large the
largest economy in the world um it's
it's it's big global responsibility to
um
address the issue and resolve it in your
eyes what are the big remaining
construction sites what still needs to
be done to avoid something like 2008
well you still have a lot of work we
still collectively have a lot of work to
do on the financial sector reform for
instance the financial sector
excesses
with the interconnectedness that we had
at the time created uh the massive
crisis that we've gone through in the
last five years
that needs to be reformed and that
reform needs to be completed the mission
is not yet accomplished but you're
positive
desperately positive yes
thank you very much thank you for
talking with us
you